[Music]
the upcoming john wick prequel series
the continental consists of three
episodes and was originally supposed to
be broadcast by the us channel stars
however according to media reports the
series will now be broadcast by the us
streaming service peacock instead
peacock president kelly campbell
expresses her joy about this deal for
example the three john wick movies which
are also exclusively available on
peacock are among the most watched films
in the streaming service the partnership
with lionsgate is an honor she says and
they will ensure that the continental
becomes one of the streaming highlights
of the coming year with the help of nbc
universal's full power the plot is set
in 1970s new york and revolves around
the young criminal winston scott also
well known from the movies winston
fights his way through the underworld
and wants to take over the hotel the
continental which serves as a meeting
place and hideout for numerous hitmen
and criminals in addition to colin
waddell as young winston scott we get to
see mel gibson as cormac peter green as
young uncle charlie ayo midae attagon as
charon and jeremy bob as mayhew among
others each of the three episodes will
be about 90 minutes long with the book
of eli director albert hughes handling
the production of episodes one and three
while the lord of the rings the rings of
power director charlotte branstrom will
take over the second episode the series
is scheduled for release next year at
which point we can also see the fourth
john wick movie in theaters on march
24th 2023
the hunger games the ballad of songbirds
and snakes has been in full production
for almost a year and now a first
picture is available it shows the two
main actors rachel zegler as lucy gray
and tom blythe is cory alanis snow while
gray is new to the franchise snow is
already known from the previous parts as
the dictatorial president of panam in
the upcoming prequel however he will be
seen in his younger years where he is
still working as a supervisor behind the
scenes of the hunger games director
francis lawrence who directed the
previous three movies recently spoke to
vanity fair about the new character gray
describing her as the anti-katniss
according to him she is musically gifted
charming a performer and does not have
much in common with the serious and
reserved main character of the original
film series as a result she arouses the
interest of the young corey elena snow
and they eventually fall in love for
snow who comes from humble beginnings
the games are extremely important lucy's
mentor sees the games as his big chance
to climb the social ladder and leave his
old life behind recent information also
concerns another new addition to the
feature film namely that viola davis is
to be added as the villain dr volumnia
gaul the character is the head game
maker of the 10th hunger games and is
said to be a very vicious figure she is
very energetic and has an almost
disturbing playful manner that does not
really fit her actions she is also said
to be in some ways a role model for the
later president corey elena snow the
hunger games the ballad of songbirds and
snakes is scheduled for release on
november 17th 2023 and is based on the
book of the same name by suzanne collins
who published the novel in may 2020
in 2020 ghost of tsushima one of sony's
best games for the past few years was
released on the playstation 4 primarily
the constant references to japanese
cinema and director akira kurosawa as
well as the breathtakingly beautiful
game world made the game created by
developer studio sucker punch
productions sell over 9 million units
within 2 years in its original form the
game in which you play the samurai jin
sakai is produced entirely in japanese
but of course it does feature
corresponding audio output and subtitles
the final movie is supposed to turn out
very similarly at least according to
director chad stahlski the john wick
director recently spoke in an interview
with collider about the way the upcoming
film will be made and it promises to be
extremely authentic due to his
connection to the japanese cult director
kurosawa among other reasons the ghost
of tsushima movie will be released in
japanese with appropriate subtitles
stahelski sees little issue with this
since western audiences are used to
reading subtitles anyway but that's not
all all the actors involved are also
expected to be from japan after all the
mongol invasion of the island of
tsushima which is the main subject of
the game was also a japanese affair sony
is said to be very much behind the idea
so it should only be a short period of
time before shooting starts there is no
exact release date for the movie yet
though given the early stage of
production we should not count on a
release in the next two years
actually the kung fu panda movie
franchise was as good as done after kung
fu panda 3 in 2016 however following the
recent success of the netflix series
kung fu panda the dragon knight those
responsible at dreamworks now seem to
believe that there is potential in a
fourth film and have made an official
announcement the film is expected to hit
theaters in march 2024 and will no
longer be distributed by 20th century
studios but by universal pictures also
joining the team is producer peter
hastings who was equally invested in
kung fu panda the dragon knight in the
original lead role we will again be able
to see or rather hear jack black is the
skilled martial artist panda poe however
the exact plot deals are not known as of
yet which also means that we don't know
whether the film will tie in with kung
fu panda the dragon knight or with kung
fu panda 3 in any way we are looking
forward to more information about kung
fu panda 4 which will be out in march
2024 and in the meantime we will keep
you posted
robert de niro's last appearance in his
starring role as a mobster was in 2019's
the irishman and now the 79 year old is
back at it again with his very next
project his new movie is called wiseguys
and it's based on the true story of
frank costello and vito genovese the two
mobsters are successful crime bosses who
compete against each other one day
genovese wants to kill frank costello
but the latter survives badly injured
and subsequently tries to turn his back
on the mob life the highlight is that
robert de niro will not only play frank
costello but also veto genovese at the
same time there's still no further news
about the cast or the plot but we do
know that the script will be written by
nicholas pallegi he already has some
experience as the author of the cult
films casino and goodfellas when it
comes to classic mob movies which should
certainly please genre fans goodfellas
producer irvin winkler is also coming
back meaning that de niro seems to value
the skills of those who already had
success with their projects back then
the only person missing to complete the
crew is martin scorsese's director one
might think however good morning vietnam
director barry levinson who at least has
experience working with robert de niro
will be directing the film precisely
when wise guys will be released has not
been determined so far
when the extremely inexpensive saw which
cost 1.2 million dollars to produce was
released almost 18 years ago no one
expected that a 10th part of the series
would one day be released we have known
more about it for a few months though
because saw 10 is indeed in the works
kevin grudert is to direct the film
which would be the third time he directs
a saw movie since he is one of the saw
greats behind the scenes not much is
known about the contents yet but the
return of jigsaw actor tobin bell is
considered certain after rumors have
been circulating for quite some time
already this also means the film will
not be a sequel but rather a prequel as
jigsaw already died in the third film
the last movie spiral from the book of
saw had two top class main actors with
comedian chris rock and samuel l jackson
but failed to win over the audience
overall became the financially weakest
film in the series in fact tobin bell
did not play a part in this film and
only appears in one photo which is the
reason why it is now hoped that his
return to the camera will bring about
the great revival of the movie series
the script was written by josh stolberg
and pete goldfinger both of whom have
been writing scripts for the saw
franchise for quite some time some
sources claim that saw 10 will take
place shortly before saw 3 and hence
just before jigsaw's death but this has
not been officially confirmed yet but at
least the official release date was
announced a few days ago and that is
planned for october 27 2023
and that was the news for this week if
you still haven't had enough take a look
at our big preview of the lord of the
rings the rings of power in our new
originals episode you can find out
everything there is to know about the
exciting amazon series coming up soon on
september 2nd 2022
[Music]